head coach of the New Orleans Saints
Sean Payton how are you coach Payton
I'm doing fine rich thanks for having me
on it's not often you hear a former
right tackle display but amazing it's
amazing that Zach's do he's done a great
job
he sure has so what does this record
mean to you coach well look I I said
this during the week to our players I
think number one it becames it's
significant obviously and there's so
many people that are involved in it I
think as a coach the pressure that we
felt was to make sure we played well and
won when it happened I think there'll be
a time later where we look back on the
accomplishment in the amount and but I
think the the winning was most important
that night and I think you know putting
putting the game together like we did on
Monday Night Football I you know we
talked the night before them
each player you know going out playing
his best to make sure this night was
special for for the team but also for
Drew and I think they did that so man it
doesn't seem like 13 years though it
seems like six or seven years and it
doesn't seem like it's been that long of
a period of time and I think the thing
that still drives him that still drives
me or our players that have been around
quite a while is the opportunity to win
try to win another Super Bowl yeah I
mean and so much has been discussed of
that moment I guess 13 years ago now or
13 seasons ago now when you arrive and
you know the as we're seeing a hurricane
bearing down on the Florida Panhandle
while we speak right now Katrina had
just ravaged the town I'm wondering and
we're talking so much about breezes
shoulder and the decision that was going
down with Miami in New Orleans what was
your first conversation with Drew Brees
as head coach of the Saints was it
involved in trying to get him there with
his free agent process yeah I
remember specifically number one and we
were at the combine it was the last day
of the combine and we found out that San
Diego was was making the decision to let
him go you know we were in a quarterback
search mode at that point you know we
were looking closely at the quarterbacks
in the draft and also looking at a lot
of quarterbacks that we felt might be
able to hold the fort you know give us a
few good years until we found the the
right guy and and so a lot was going on
with us as an organization in the search
for that position when he became
available we spent some time obviously
the injury was something that we had to
discuss we felt we felt that there was
some risk there and yet it was worth
investing in so very quickly we were
involved in calling him I can recall
speaking to him he was in Birmingham
rehabbing with Andrews at the time
meanwhile Josh McCown was someone Josh
was actually on a flight to New Orleans
after Dru had taken his visit and once
Drew would call drew taken his visit
went from New Orleans then he went on to
Miami and then the following week called
and said he was coming to New Orleans
Josh was on a flight connecting
somewhere in Charlotte or Atlanta and
when Drew committed to us and quickly we
had to call him and say hey you know
we're not going to have that opportunity
available right now but so there was
there was a lot of digging going on
relative to the position but I think the
feeling from our standpoint was there
was going to be some risk we had to take
some risk with the idea that you know on
the back end it could turn out to be
something really really good I don't
know that anymore
one of us would have expected what's
happened since it is amazing it really
is amazing how fragile those moments
were and what a foundation you and drew
brees have been able to build and build
upon at the time Sean Payton here on the
Rich Eisen show knowing it's your first
shot at being an HC in this league like
this
right knowing what system you wanted to
bring in the scheme you wanted to bring
what did you see and breeze that you
thought this is my guy
well there were there were two or three
traits that you just couldn't you
couldn't ignore it smart tough accurate
that had followed him man all through
college
and you knew that he had the that grit
some of those other essential things
that were going to help him in his
recovery in his rehab in other words if
he couldn't recover from the shoulder
injury then it's probably likely that no
one would have been able to because it
was something that there was no
precedent relative to the injury he had
it wasn't like well he had an ACL this
is the year the percentages or he had an
ankle or whatever this was a fully torn
rotator cuff shoulder injury for a
right-handed passer so all those
intangibles but but the athleticism the
intelligence and the accuracy I think
were things that it stood out and you
know that the challenge for us was you
know recruiting you know with the city
that was still happened in shambles yeah
and it's interesting we have Reggie Bush
on yesterday coach where he said that he
didn't he wanted to get a trade to the
to the Jets and instructed him none of
it and told his guy or knee loose as we
all know a legend in the NFL and the
football world you told him that's not
happening that's what he said yeah it
wasn't quite that wasn't quite the
language but you know it was all
happening within a month and we were
able to secure drew and move move
towards the draft and with more a little
bit more freedom with that pick at
number two and hopefully take the best
available player and so as you start
getting ready for that process and
Reggie fell that first night fell I mean
you know obviously
mario was taken by the texans now we're
on the phone with with him and they were
making this selection and ortiz is
marketing guy so it's rare that he gets
even a chance to get on the phone
conversation but if anyone doesn't know
my corn skein he'll find a way to get on
the conversation and in any I'll never
forget the condescending coach you know
look I know you're gonna do a great job
in this league but the kid doesn't want
to come and play there so you need to
get this trade to the Jets worked out
and he went on for about five minutes
and then quickly we put that to bed it
was an all time conversation one really
a conversation but anyway so there were
these pieces that came into place in in
different ways and you know the same
relative to me getting hired yeah I had
just gone to Green Bay and thought I was
gonna get there Packers job and you know
was on the interview here and really
wasn't paying much attention to it there
wasn't a lot of interest because of the
challenges you saw I mean this this was
a tough job before Katrina and then post
Katrina it just looked miserable it
really is amazing and then you it's
interesting you mentioned Green Bay
which brings me to my next question for
you Sean Payton where you see you know
Aaron Rodgers sometimes say some things
into a microphone that we in the media
term is a passive-aggressive way to talk
about the scheme and the coach and
there's a book out now about Belichick
in which there's a large section about
the relationship between Brady and
Belichick and the whole concept of well
when you're around each other for years
in a marriage there's gonna be some some
problems it seems like I never hear that
about you
and Drew Brees why why does it work so
well do you think with you I you know I
was asked that last week and honestly I
don't ever take it for granted I think
that the the goal is clear and is common
and I I don't I don't know I it's it's
you know I think people feel like you
guys must be close friends you're around
I mean I coach and he plays and in man
there's a tremendous amount of respect I
think that that certainly we have as
coaches for the work he puts in in the
preparation that goes on the attention
to detail and I feel like that same
challenges always on us as teachers and
coaches to come up with the best plan
and to put our best foot forward and to
really put our players in a position to
have success but I would guess that each
relationship somewhat different maybe a
little bit but yeah I mean like I said
in the onset it doesn't seem like first
off it doesn't seem like 13 years and
and you know I mean he can be corny
sometimes and I mean what do you mean
I'm trying to come up with something
like he can be a real goofball or corny
and I'm sure I can be the same way or
but you have a district one asked me did
he ever do something and make you really
angry yes it really wasn't angry but
when we went down to the oil spill in
south of Louisiana after the the oil
will came up from the ocean surface
wouldn't when we had that tragedy and we
went down to help all the families be
their feet feed them aside on a grass
and we were on live with Anderson Cooper
and it was Breeze myself and then
Anderson Cooper back in Atlanta or
wherever he was and you know you have
the little ear pieces in and we're gonna
cut to you and the moral of this story
is don't ever let breeze go first
Anderson asked him a series of questions
drew elaborated pontificated whatever
you want to say on each one of these
questions and each time he answered one
of these questions I thought well there
was another topic and I might be able to
talk about when he comes to me and then
there goes another topic and then pretty
soon I'm down to like one in my pocket
you know and it was the state Pelican
they were washed with Ivory soap and I
thought I'm gonna hang on to that and
then sure enough at the very end ruses
yeah and the pelicans even
getting clean with the Ivory soap and
then we click over coach we're going to
you now and I looked at Brees and he
handed me he handed me like a Hooters
chicken wing with just all boom there's
nothing left to the story so you don't
want to be that like the second person
in an interview with him but noted I'll
make sure that that that does not happen
if I ever have the two of you on at the
same time coach yeah a few more minutes
left here with Sean Payton on the Rich
Eisen show let's get to the here and now
Mike Thomas is is his Twitter handles
can't guard Mike sure looks like that's
the fact and he catches everything he is
his completion rate barista to Mike
right now is off the charts he's only
missed on three connections the two of
them what what makes that work so well
in your mind well it's a great question
not number one the two of them worked
their tails off you know Mike is someone
that stays after was there early
there's no walkthrough snaps even though
it's a walk through for him it's full
speed there's a physicality and a
presence with him his size his strength
he's very difficult at the line of
scrimmage if you're trying to press him
and I think that's one of the things
that that stands out most you know in
Thursday's I'll go out there and kind of
you get a lot of bump and run man
Thursday's our third downs we're
simulating that as a coach what kind of
press these guys and have some fun with
them and and I did this a year ago with
Mike and he released off the ball with
his hands like walk in right away I
remember just being stunned and for the
next couple days I felt like I was in a
car accident night and I've done this
for years with Colston and you name it
Debra Henderson Lance Moore Robert
Meachem this is the first time that I
had a finger pointing sideways I had a
bruise on my chest and it just felt like
I don't want to ever do that to him
again that makes sense
that makes sense and then you're in your
kid from from San Antonio who you traded
up into the first round I'll be honest
with you I was sitting there on the
draft set and I heard you traded up I'm
like okay he goes
Lamar Jackson and you took Marcus
Davenport instead how has his
development seems like he played his
best game to date
he sure did I was real I was real
pleased with how we played the other
night he was slowed a little bit in
training camp with a groin injury he's
healthy now and the last two weeks
you're starting to see I mean you know
he's a young player but very quickly
getting acclimated and comfortable over
on the right side he's long he's got
real good strength and he'll be his
development will be important for us
defensively and as a team all right and
then the last question for you here
coach it is with a little bit of self
interest I'm not gonna lie I'm always
going to be straightforward with you as
always but I'm also representing a very
large section of the fantasy football
playing public Alvin Camaro a mere nine
touches in mark Ingram's return how
panicked should I be about Camaros - I
think man I'm sitting tight but it was
it was one of those games honestly where
I would I wouldn't have guessed he had
nine touches in yet we had some big I
mean long scoring plays that were quick
strike passes when that happens then
your total play counts down and then
your amount of touches gets reduced but
Twitter has gotten to a point now where
within like a half a day I'll have just
some awful tweets about how I have just
crushed someone's fantasy with Taysom
Hill taking a handoff there touchdown in
chimera on the bench were committing it
just it's unbelievable because
ultimately there's there's a lot of
players that are talented Alvin
certainly is one of them and I wouldn't
worry but I was unaware that it was only
nine nine opportunities but it didn't
take long before I found out that that
was the number yeah
the term is vultured by the way in the
in the in the fantasy industry yes in
the industry likes it
so take some Hill getting it I can
handle Ingram getting a couple shots
from the one but tasting Hill vulturing
that Camaro touchdown that's a bitter
pill it's a bitter pill so how concerned
should I be do you think that I I'm I
find me you this is me if I'm you I'm
sitting tight okay that kind of like the
alvin kamara fantasy prospects i like
the player a lot obviously and right
hopefully we'll find other ways to get
him into the end zone
okay just understand this look you do
what you have to do clearly you have
your own I just don't want to make sure
that you can we see each other combine
Senior Bowl wherever that is my next I
don't get that like look look no it's
just get the friendship look know just
know this on the one-yard line or two
yard line in the future future games
just know you owe me one that's all
John really appreciate our chats you
take care again congrats on the the
milestone you you you were had a
front-row seat for it you're the one
who's making the plays and making calls
and and being part of clearly an
operation that Drew Brees is crushing so
congrats on that rich I appreciate you
bet you take care of that Sean Payton
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience